so a lot of times people go into this
being nice right and I and I see this in
the comments they probably did it
because of snoring or something like
that they didn't weirdly think sharing a
bedroom with their spouse was inherently
bad and you know I I understand giving
people the benefit of the doubt I
understand there's exceptions guys but
you know there's something about working
through discomfort you know we used to
have things that bothered us about our
husband bothered us about our wi and we
would figure out Solutions you know and
you you wouldn't separate but we all
know that separating Grooms is the first
step to a divorce